is this the same triangle when you were
with your wife and your wife had a
was pregnant is this the same one you're
you're sorry your girlfriend and
someone asked and please if i'm
mispronouncing this name or miss saying
it rewrite it someone asked a while ago
did someone named steve
rear
not greer steve ryde steve reed examine
your
girlfriend
i don't know the doctor's name i was in
the in the room i saw the ultrasound but
i don't know her doctor's name i'm sure
she knows has already rostrated
no
yes maybe is roger lear the doctor
no he was not the the medical doctor who
examined her
he um
was involved in researching the case
later
but
um
when um
she passed the cord and the placenta
that was um time for the medical people
the scientists to come in and examine
and this claim that it was an alien or
that i said it was an alien it's just a
damn lie i've never said any such thing
but see again these are people who
are in a position to make up a story and
become an important part of something
that's worldwide news so yeah he said
one claim was that i killed the baby
that i performed an abortion on this
woman total lie
you know uh
i am totally anti-abortion i don't care
who knows it uh
and i was uh trained as a midwife
uh
as i said
second highest score out of 40 people
i would never in this world dream of
performing an abortion that's just
i've delivered a number of babies
but
the claim that i you know killed this
baby because it was half alien was just
a wild claim gets attention that's what
it's that's what it's all about
something that got the news is out there
get my two cents worth in look at me
look at me
i knew travis in the past you know
i dated my uh
with his friend or whatever
travis where can people find out more
about you
and what's next travis traviswalton.com
what's next for you
um
a
big budget remake of fire in the sky
it's their idea and i'm all for it
because i'd love to straighten out a few
things
you know there's some misconceptions
about what happened
uh
people have come to
um
based on
the movie i think the movie was a huge
accomplishment in terms of breaking down
people's resistance to the idea that it
could happen because they were sort of
vicariously able to
live it themselves
but
i always try to warn people don't don't
treat it as a documentary it was
entertainment
and
hollywood does that sort of thing so
i'm going to try to keep
retain
the script approval this time around